okay hello everyone well we are going to
look at bugs we are getting close to the
end of the
cycle for version 13 of wolfram language
and this is the time when we try and
close
off as many reported bugs that have
affected people as we can
so today we're going to look at a couple
of
different areas
these are things that have been
highlighted in our
external redmine bug reporting system
accessible to pre-release testers and
people who are
interested can apply for the pre-release
program
i send an email to pre-release
wolfram.com
right yep
um or support at wolfram.com i don't
want to brick but yeah okay so let's
start off with image and signal
processing
okay so 48 reports resolved in 1365 have
been resolved in twelve three
okay subset of recently resolved issues
okay
uh
that's just a sample of to to to show
you know bugs that have been finished is
this typical of the size of bugs that we
are seeing in this list or are these
small bugs
well
i'm asking
i'm asking
i'm sorry the the size of the bug itself
you're asking i might say
no no no i'm i'm saying
these appear to be
you know fairly corner case type things
they're bugs they're very important for
polishing but we're not looking here at
strategic issues
is that because there aren't strategic
issues in the bugs database in this area
of functionality or is that because we
didn't address them
uh more strategic bugs i i guess comes
to us as suggestions and we address them
in a batch as new features that go out
it's harder to address them
as bug fixes
all right all right let's take a look at
some of these but what i want to know is
if
if there are people
watching listening to this
who
use our product all the time
and they're like oh my gosh there's this
horrifying bug i've reported it eight
times
it's really slowing me down is that
going to be in this list or is that not
going to be in this list
it should be it should get get okay so
so
stephen can i say something about that
yes
for red mine what people usually care
about they have a particular workflow
right they're trying to get from a to b
right programmatically and then they run
into an issue right i mean
yes i mean there may be point issues but
it can completely you know like screw up
your
you know you you you will try to follow
yeah so
yes there may be point issues but yes
they also matter if you know it's part
of a bigger picture
fair enough but i mean there's some
issues which are you can't get there
from here and there are other issues
where well that's annoying but i can
work around it
sure now we want to fix we want to
polish everything
but
you know the ones where people are like
i guess i just can't get from here to
there those have to be the highest
priority
and have we successfully prioritized
those things
i think so i think we look look at it
whenever i look at the raw data where is
the raw data
can somebody uh send me the link please
you mean the raw data in red mine or
whatever yep yep
okay jk you have that
i'll do it as well
okay and send me the link to the ones
that are in this category okay
jay can you do that please
you speak
speak up yep speak up please
right now
am i getting this
working on it
sorry okay all right okay
chromaticity protrusions on large
gamut
limit what is this what am i what am i
doing here
click here what no what's going on what
is this okay
so what's the way we organize okay so so
let me let me comment on something this
nonsense with this enable dynamics thing
that is supposed to be fixed for 13
right
that's an example of something that is
in your face every day needs to be fixed
so i assume that that's getting fixed
i know that isn't our subject today but
that's something that i don't know it's
getting fixed right but somebody has to
chase that to make sure it gets taking
notes here
where should i i can take oh no no come
on you've got to have organized this
properly who is taking notes
i'll take a note i'll take a note
if nobody speaks up here
or stay funky you
yeah yeah i can because this is the
dynamic warning that it's a john full
sting that
right and that's probably going to need
okay but for for this meeting we
organized it just like every one of
these items just has a notebook that
kind of shows you know
the thing all right but i mean
these are not
are these controversial bugs
i don't think this one is that i i i get
the suggestion it or bug it
it's not a suggestion it's a point
it's a bug
where it plots a point outside of the
chromaticity triangle or whatever it is
outside of this triangle
is a bug
how could it not be a bug
no this one is a bug the rest of them
are suggestions so that's why i sorry
west water suggestions uh the rest of
the items for image processing in the
left notebook
so are you telling me there are no bugs
there are only suggestions
because i don't believe that
i didn't look at raw material from red
mine okay so
we are not properly prepared here
well okay so you're gonna get this bug
fixed i mean what what exactly is this
bug
shows protrusions for system color
profiles that have large gamut
okay do we know why that happens
we're currently looking at a cross
section of the 3d version of
chromaticity plots the chromatic plot 3d
and then that plane gets
drawn on the 2d plane
i don't know where this is exactly
coming from but we have discussed with
giulio doing a projection of the whole
3d gamut instead of just doing the
intersection
i mean it doesn't seem like it's the
right thing for me to debug this here
and it doesn't seem like it doesn't
sound like you have the right person
here julio is the person who's dealing
with this
giulio julia is still doing some of the
color projects that he has started
working on okay so this is but this one
doesn't show it then then the 2d is just
the bulk
okay it's just a bug right i mean it's
the
this thing
okay i mean surely somebody can find it
it doesn't seem like the most heinous
bug in the world but it's
it you know somebody should find it
yep
uh how do i log into this
you don't have anything on the screen so
i'm not sure what you're doing how do i
log in to the suv
it required that the the link you sent
me requires login
um wait check hang on a second
the last time you did not want to look
at this so that's why we didn't like i
suppose so this time i think i have to
look at it because i don't think this is
an adequate list
i i think by the time you're telling me
these are only suggestions i know this
isn't an adequate list
okay well last time you specifically did
not want to take a look at it so just
give me a second here okay
[Music]
but it wasn't useful to send me a link
that
to a login i don't have
i'm resetting the password and i'll i'll
send it to you in text this give me a
second here
okay
i'll send it to your email
i'm fine that's fine
i i don't quite know why i think like
this couldn't be included in the
notebook rather than having to that was
my decision because last time
you did not want to like show this i
like like you specifically like
explorated me like doing that i
shouldn't have included that and you
didn't want to look at all the raw stuff
all
right
okay so local adaptive binarize
uses the mean and standard deviation of
the neighborhood to compute the local
threshold
please add a method to use otsu's method
to convert i have no idea
binarizer
the user is asking for more control over
how that
how that threshold is is computed or or
want to hard code it to a specific
threshold that's the reasonable request
and and we're going to look into that
yes
the image effect function well that was
sort of a catch-all function
yeah it's an interesting point it was
implemented before neural nets
right
we can implement so many people i'm
asking this question i'm asking this
question it was implemented using
classical image processing before neural
nets correct correct yes okay so there
are two questions one is
are there are the effects that we
currently have capable of being done
faster
with neural nets and two are there a
boatload of other effects we could do
yes personally
both questions personally i think that a
lot of these exotic effects
are well prototyped in the function
repository
i'm not sure that having
a bunch of you know weird effects built
into the system with string names in
this function is the right way to go
i was thinking roughly the same function
repository or network repository we were
we were already looking at some effect
networks that could be converted and
placed in the net repository
well
they could be then linked from the
function repository no no no no but i
mean the problem is how is anybody going
to find it like okay let me give an
example this torn frame effect does that
is that in image effects or not
that one is yes that was it so i've i
mean i you know so let me let me take an
example of that so i mean in um let's
say i
uh
do a
um
let's see what is it called screen
notebook screen capture
notebook screen capture no
what is it called to capture a notebook
current notebook image
okay
of
let's get the notebook called download
oh great well we'll find something here
let's pick that one
i'm just trying to understand where this
actually works
okay so now okay so
there we have that
okay so now we say image effect
and now how do we tell it what we
actually need which is i want to tear it
at some point down this page that one
that one you would have to crop or image
take at whatever size you want
let's assume it's it's at the
size i want
it it's hard to see it in this one
because it's a lot of white around it
okay
okay well who knows okay i mean this
particular thing
it's not clear that image effect on its
own
is um
uh
you know
it's not clear the image effect on its
own is the right thing to implement this
see what i'm saying because this really
has parameters
and we do have we do have some
parameters for these boundary effects in
image effect i think some categories
that are really commonly used and wanted
could still get added to image effect or
get improved in image effects or authors
just become functions in their own right
sure sure i mean it's just some of the
image effect things are too obscure but
i think it'd be worthwhile to try and
figure out let's do a review
of image effect where we try and
distinguish three cases case one they
become functions in their own right
case two
they become function repository items
case three
they i i think becoming pure neural net
repository items
is fine to achieve the functionality
it's not useful for discoverability
making sense yes
okay so
let's um
i'll send you an email with all the
information if you want to look at the
redmine thing but yep i think it's
working now
some using my
the second email has the actual password
in it i
didn't take the first one that i sent
the third email as a link for the image
uh redmine issues related to images that
people reported
is it working yup
okay
so we selected certain items from that
that's on the agenda like not everything
you know it's uh
okay but so
where we can i sort by priority here
okay so where is this one for example on
the list that you're showing me
okay is it on there or not
well i i mean i took the list um
that i discussed this with shadi
oh look there's something listed as
urgent
yeah but i assume that's getting fixed
oh if you click on it um you'll see the
activity
i don't see that getting fixed and then
um that internal bug report has the link
to our internal bug report okay but but
it was it said version 12.2 was its
target what happened
you can't tag it as urgent and then have
it not fixed for two releases
i can take the blame on that i that that
has probably completely skipped me but
we are also very much moving a lot of
no good excuse but moving a lot of
resources to video raffle
and that one just didn't get enough
attention
but you can't have something that's
tagged as urgent here and either it's
incorrectly prioritized or
that and i don't understand how it fails
to be on the list that i'm being shown
here
also
i would like to uh mention that this
priority is set by the external reporter
so not okay well then okay are we fixing
these priorities because that's not
going to work
who is determining these priorities
somebody says i think it's a red mind
it's a wave that users can indicate that
this is you know urgent for them like
some some people you know okay do we
have a mechanism for look what's urgent
for one person what's unurgent for
somebody else may actually be something
it's really important but they're just a
a meeker milder less pushing exactly so
i wouldn't put too much you know right
so so i want to know
if that's the case
if we're going to manage this we have to
be able to have our version of what the
priority is
which we do inside the bug report and
that gets reviewed by you know so i
should just ignore this basically it's
what you're telling me
well i wouldn't ignore it i mean this is
a specific user like there's no extra
details here like why why it's set to
urgent but yeah well then we should ask
people to do that we should tell people
if you want to set it to a high priority
you've got to explain why i mean this
one was set by sander right we know okay
right there's a previous disaster so yes
we can ask him like why he said that's
specific but i think we should
specifically ask the question
what
uh you know if somebody is going to set
something above normal priority we
should tell them as part of the
instructions tell us why they may have a
very good reason yeah or it may just be
that they were frustrated because they
needed to solve something that day
and they thought this should work and it
didn't
exactly yeah we we should do that yeah
okay
and and sometimes they say that and
sometimes they don't i mean i know but
so we should and if somebody is somebody
looking at these reports
and they if they don't if they put it to
a higher priority and they don't say why
we can even have an automated system
that sends back something well they
can't tell automatically whether they
explained it because it's just enough
right every report gets reviewed and it
gets an internal bug report that gets
assigned to the developer so you know
it's
this system is the user facing or the
pre-release you know tester
this is a decent suggestion it's not
really for this group is it but that's a
decent suggestion
right no that that would be for me
okay
seems like a good suggestion i agree
the toolbar in general needs to get some
love when we have time
well is that something that requires ux
work or is that something that is where
the ux is either trivial or done
um i think the ux is okay i wouldn't
want to get back to ux with that there
are a good number of bugs and
suggestions that we haven't wait wait
wait wait
this meeting was supposed to be about
bugs not suggestions why am i seeing
suggestions here
i think you wanted both
if i remember correctly you wanted both
bugs and suggestions
i mean we we had we had a meeting before
this with um arnold shadi charles
and stefan basically we i mean we try to
get a list that will make this music
productive
there there are some bugs where
which is so the point is this we have a
version coming up bugs have to be fixed
if there are a bunch of excuses for why
bugs aren't getting fixed this is as
good a place to air them as any
but otherwise
you know priority high priority bugs
need to get fixed for this version as we
all know right and they are i mean you
know
well okay
but we see no evidence of that here
i mean this
well that was so there's a good question
how many points
wrong
how many of these are wrong answers how
many of these are crashes
how many of these are things which
definitively
stop somebody in their tracks
versus things like it would be nice to
have a slider here
do we even have that categorization in
red mine i don't know in in our internal
bugs database we do say this is a crash
this is a wrong behavior
well i mean look can i can i feel like
i'm sorry sorry like this is
there's a resolved issue right image
compose is three times slower in version
13 than 12 right because it's about 10
down but with him right here
says resolved says result yeah all right
so that that's an example of somebody
right maybe this was detected internally
as well but you know somebody outside as
a prereleaser
tester uh where we found that yeah found
right and and and we fixed it so
you know that system is working and okay
so now here
this says feedback
i don't understand what that means that
says find geometric transform is
behaving erroneously what does that mean
does it mean it's giving the wrong
answer or does that mean
it's you know there are multiple things
it could do and it's doing one of them
and the user didn't like the way the one
it did
to look at the details here let me check
but why didn't that make it why didn't
something like that make it onto this
list
okay i don't understand what is the
criterion for things to i mean just
things which seem entertaining to
discuss is not a good criterion for this
list
well we why did that one make it into
this list we we
i mean that would have been too much
you know too many items for
what was prioritizing these these items
we we looked for bugs that were still
open right so there's some resolved
issues in here right there's no point in
you know going over a resolved issue for
example the image composed being slower
in version three oh i agree it's not
worth it we don't want to go over it so
that was removed from that list there's
some things that are just you know like
shoddy or developer there's just no
you know it's it's
know what
it's still being reviewed in the sense
that right
there's no information
it's still being reviewed as and we
don't understand what the point is or
it's still being reviewed as in people
didn't get to it
so in other words the thing i'm trying
to stamp out is these things where
a bug
gets through this version
because by golly nobody paid attention
to it
so so there are bugs that um we brought
up and the developers agree that it's a
bug and
felt like
they they i mean they do plan to fix it
wait wait we need to make sure they're
going to fix it right not just they plan
to fix it but oops they didn't fix it
right
right
if you allow me to say i mean we at
least in our case we know when there is
a bug which is reported from hand mine
from internal or whatever way we always
check them make sure that we can fix
them some are obvious to fix immediately
we fix them
some may require more work and then we
hope that by the time we release or the
next version we fix them so there is no
no no no no no no so what should happen
here the purpose of this meeting should
be the following
there is a bug
it's not so easy to fix
is this something that it's worth
going to a lot of effort to fix
or can we punt on this
that's what this meeting should be about
not oh there's a feature at that you
know we might add it's a little fringe
somewhere
and you know we can discuss it it's not
a great use of time the thing we need to
do is make sure that no nothing which is
you know where somebody says you know
for a given bug there's several
different dimensions that's how
important is it
and that's how difficult is it to fix
right
and
you know
if it's easy to fix
and everybody's just like okay we fixed
this we you know it's under control we
can do it we don't need to discuss it
okay so let me let me discuss
is where you where i'm going to hear
back from you oh we didn't fix it for
this version even though it's an
important bug because it was too hard
that's what i don't want to hear after
the fact
you get what i'm saying
yeah i understand i'm let me i'm trying
to make a new uh in one second
a new filter for you to take a look at
which are just bugs that are in progress
i think that's that's what you really
want then so let me send it you want me
to send it an email or
another one
okay
okay so what what happened to this bug
this looks like a sensibly reported bug
what happened to it
so the internal version
so there are two bug reports as the
internal bug reports and where is this
reported what was a year ago a year ago
a year ago
okay so what's what's happened to this
this specific issue there are notebooks
attached and images attached i again
haven't looked at i we don't on on a
regular daily basis we don't check red
mine however a lot of these are reported
internally so we look at all of them all
of them are all about there's an
internal bug report link so there's you
know i mean
you know and they're assigned to shoddy
so it's you know it's up to her to uh
to review those okay so i i've got the
following question this was reported a
year ago it seems bad
it's much worse than these little things
about you know the fact that it would be
nice to have a slider in the in the
image toolbar
i you know i'm kind of upset that the
list here is kind of a whitewash list
now i can confirm that both of those
internal bugs are fixed
these ones here so why didn't that feed
back to the red mine
thing that i don't know
okay what's our process for that
that they should have been they should
have been
okay so it's a bug in the bug process
yes it's yeah the tester didn't do that
they normally are but okay
okay so this is fixed
so if i run this now what was it fixed
in 12 3
one of them yes let me check the other
one as well
one virtual result in twelve three zero
the other one does not have a resolution
okay so it doesn't have a resolution so
what's going on no it doesn't doesn't
have a resolution version sorry that
that's how can that be i thought we
should always put the resolution version
but it was fixed in may
so i think so something went wrong here
so what went wrong
which one are you talking about right
now
four one zero nine seven two four
we should always have a resolution
version when something is fixed i have
no idea how that's marked as fixed and
closed but doesn't have a resolution
resolution change from pending to as
designed
come on what happened there
well it's a comment from david
there
he resolved it
okay the results are actually right
and we're wrong before and this is why
so what's going on here so
was the report incorrect what happened
now i have to again i have to look at
the notebook to see if the other bug
properly addresses the actual book that
was reported in that external report
okay so wait a minute
here's why the transformation whatever
does not belong to similarity
transformation class it is a fine
because all three scaling factors are
different
okay
therefore finding the similarity will
give you error
what is needed is to switch
transformation class from similarity to
affine which will be precise okay and
then somebody just closed the bug
but i don't understand why
you know that seems like
a silly thing from our i mean okay so
the basic point was somebody said what
is the what is the similarity transform
that takes
this picture of a duck that has been
distorted with an affine transformation
to this other picture of a duck
or something and it isn't a similarity
transform it's it is an affine transform
but it is not an accurate fit to a
similarity transform and what do we do
in that case do we just silently fail or
what do we do
i i think what what was happening before
and i'll have to confirm with this one
is that we just give a similarity
transform with a larger error
fine geometric transform gives you the
right thing to do
does it give the errors it does the
result is the error comma transformation
matrix
then i have to agree that this is this
is fixed
if that's what it's doing if that's all
that was being discussed here then i
have to agree that that's
that it is as grand correct if everybody
agrees and just need to follow up it's
you know looks like somebody didn't
you know get back to the user with this
if you go back to the redmond ticket
there was a discussion uh it's still
open because the user wants a small
clarification in the documentation well
that's a reasonable point
but then why is it listed as closed as
designed
in the in the internal bug report
has that well that would be coming back
today that would be a separate report
that's a different if it's a
documentation issue
okay
okay i don't think i had seen that
somebody should report it uh stefan but
that's a different i mean maybe it was
and there are different tickets but
we need to look into that okay i'll
check that seems documentation issues
are separate from code issues in the
sense that you know like
we're not allowing bugs to kind of drift
from one you know one issue i understand
that should be in the possible issues
section of the documentation makes
perfect sense exactly
okay so let's go back
um
you know for the sake of having this
meeting be meaningful
i'm
i'm looking at these and i don't really
understand what these are again
these are things that are unresolved but
they are basically suggestions is that
correct
yes and most of them are small if you
don't want to spend time on it well it
doesn't seem store image information
about edge pixels
extracting edge pixel coordinates
the edge pixels as an edge property so
this is a suggestion
for extracting why isn't
so this has to do with in
i don't quite understand this is
basically like boundary mesh or
something you're extracting the edge of
a feature in an image is that true do
you remember what morphological graph
does
i think it's
it's a function that gets kind of a
skeleton of an image and then uh
converts that to a graph so the
suggestion here is to make sure we get
some some properties some information
about those edges that were simply
reported as an edge unweighted in that
graph
and store it as kind of an edge weight
or some additional edge properties
sorry actually ali is commenting on the
live stream that this isn't the case
read the notebook read the notebook
attached to the bug so this still has to
do with this
this bug here
is that correct
i'll i'll read that no but i mean what
we're saying what's being said is we're
not correctly closing this
okay there's some additional issue
i'll reopen it then it's it's
it looks like the uh both the developer
and the qa person interpreted as a you
know fixed issue but
well so
there's still a problem here yep you
know and i'll i just click the reopen
button and we'll take another look at it
okay so this is another comment from
sander here
uh
about
is this
i see it's numerical precision of region
membership
so does it say it's in it or does it say
it's not in it let's find out
right so i mean this is an issue we are
working on on the you know robustness of
our implementation so
it's an issue and we're working on that
what can you say a little bit more about
it
um
yes
so and essentially a regional member
with two arguments in the case of a
rectangle we have a
a closed form formula which is not
stable enough as you see there the
first coordinate of the point you know
it's ten to the six
right
and so that formula is pretty much
unstable when you get to that close
where the region member has a
you know as a function which is the
second case have a more robust stable
numerical code
right
so what i understand the point is not in
the region is it or am i
misunderstanding the point should be
outside the region right right we get
two different results yes i know but the
first result is the wrong result right
am i correct
um
yes and the first result here is the
wrong with the wrong results yes okay so
then what what is this so if i say
region member of region comma
point x y
what the heck is that
it's a you know is if you know the
region x y is a function right we return
and if you give explicit values
that's the courage version is that right
like that right yeah exactly yeah okay
but so you're saying if i do this
i get that
which is going to give the correct
result
right in this case
which it does
now for some reason this case here
does not give the correct result
so
no no it's the first case so if you add
a second argument to region member
right is the one which doesn't give the
correct result no it does look at it
it's giving the correct result
look at it for the specific value for
the talking about the actual yeah
this this this point
is not in that region
it is outside the region it is minus ten
to the minus six the region goes from
zero to fifteen
it is outside the region this is the
correct result
right yeah i think so
right charles
okay
i mean look at it it's minus yeah yeah
right so it's outside the region so
that's the correct result so the curried
form is not giving the correct result
right the operator form is not giving
the correct result right
okay so why is that it's because it's
turning it into a mesh and the mesh has
different kinds of approximations in it
is that correct correct we have
different two different algorithms for
future honey so we just need to make
sure they
you know one is most global step you
know more stable and proposals well but
i mean it may be that it's okay if that
region
was the coastline of norway
right this is not such a simple problem
change the point to like
instead of minus six make it like minus
one or like the in in the input pt pt
equals and then at the very top in this
one here let me just do this let's say
minus one one
okay it's correctly going to get false
so if i go
closer and closer to zero because that's
the right ten to the minus n
i'll just make a table here
n goes from
0 to 10. yeah then i make it 10.0 or
something just to make sure it's
numerical
okay so it did so all of those were
false but if i do 10.10 points
huh
oh strange and curious
well it's minus minus 1.0 right so it's
yeah times 10 to the minus 6.
so why isn't that so in in this case
here
i should be getting if i do region
member of this
and i say 10 to the minus 6
minus 10 to the
oh i minus 6 what am i doing here look
at this that's what's wrong
oh
okay there we go okay so it's it's just
a numerical you know at some point it's
a numerical glitch yeah
that's probably sure that should be in
the possible issues for now
yeah
can someone write that down hello
take a screenshot
right
so
this is obviously a complicated issue
because as i say if it's the coastline
of norway how does it do the region
member test
it doesn't even you know it has some
sample points what is its what is its uh
what is its
you know
how does it assume that the boundary
exists
do you understand my question charles
right i mean we if you notice for the
last
couple of versions from 12 12 18 12 3 we
started to introduce more robust uh
algorithm like uh
you know
collinear point and such where
essentially we focus on that robustness
and it's those modules we need to
propagate you know in all functions so
they can actually be the most stable
in those cases yeah but i think this is
ultimately not a winnable battle is it
i mean this is ultimately they're going
to be cases that fail am i not right
um
in principle no we should be able to
have numerical more stable algorithm
but i understand that point but i'm
asking the question if the region
is something really complicated like the
coastline of norway
how do you describe that region and then
how do you determine whether that
particular you know place on the beach
is on land or in the ocean
right so if it's a course of norway
which if i assume that is a mesh region
so the boundary is pretty much linear
right so in that case
right so we're assuming it's a linear
okay so you're saying the the
the contract is it's going to be a
piecewise linear approximation and then
get the point right whether it's on one
side or the other of that piecewise
linear approximation is that correct
yes correct and it's depend of the
different representation we have on the
type of region you provide you have to
i'm seeing another bug report here
boy
is it coming from the chat or where is
this yeah yeah yeah okay but but this
i mean this is a different group
different team that deals with this but
it will be good to know what the state
of this is
uh let me i'll look it up i'll just give
you two seconds or maybe somebody else
can help out here but we can look that
up it should be
okay all right let's come back to
uh okay i'm going to use this as a test
case
there is something that ali says
they reported
four years ago about find maximum flow
that isn't fixed so the question now is
um
lovely okay these are good
okay
so is that question no i don't want to
see suggestions here this is a bugs
meeting this is not a suggestions
meeting okay
can we be clear on that
guys yep yeah yeah i got it and let me
then try to find you uh
okay so the question is
now sandra is commenting on the previous
bug that the thing was a polygon and
you're right it's a polygon and charles
is saying that we should for polygons we
should get this right
definitively
right charles and that's what you're
saying that there's a method we know to
get this definitively correct
am am i is that right charles or is that
not right
charles
hello charles
can you hear me yep so now we can yep
um yes yes definitely yes we we are
working on those robust algorithms
just to be clear the algorithm you're
talking about when the region specified
is a polygon it will definitively get it
based on machine comparisons based on
the the
you know based on the comparison you
would expect
of
those well i guess
it's not completely obvious what the
comparison is and as you get towards
machine epsilon it's going to get more
complicated
exactly and you depend on the
method right and
and yes
but the issue is why is it failing at
ten to the minus 6 which is far above
machine epsilon
no so that's why i say it's more about
the formula which is implemented so
there's a numerical error propagation
in that formula so we use two different
expressions and this does that's the
problem there
that's a lot of propagation 10 hours of
magnitude how come
uh i don't know yeah we are we are
checking that and we hope to solve that
soon
okay
okay
all right okay all right i'll put a link
in the chat and to your email for the
open bugs
in red
let's take a look at the ones that were
actually bugs here
um
okay not suggestions we're not looking
at that okay canonicalized polygon
crashes when evaluated repeatedly
charles yes so that's the name issue we
are working on actively is an important
issue we know and we are doing our best
and essentially it's a
memory allocation issue how to track but
we are working on it
so it's a memory leak
um yes so pretty much there is a point
always jumping
around it's depend on the c constant it
works in some cases and when you've
evaluated cash so yeah
you're chasing that down
no
that's not right it crashed
the very first thing crashed
just crashed the kernel just now
right it crashed immediately it didn't
crash on a memory leak
it crashed immediately
yes as i said you know it's but it says
crashes when it's run repeatedly but it
didn't it crashed immediately it's
that's why it's depend on the machine
the sea constant it's happened
like in my case it doesn't even happen
and you have to change the state of the
kernel for it to happen
so it's a complex uh
issue in the you know a pointer we have
in
you know in our implementation when we
are reconstructing the polygon
and we know i assume that we're running
this with appropriate
you know validation harnesses for the
low-level code and all that kind of
thing so we know
you know when it writes outside some
array bound we know where that is right
we're using modern tools to figure this
out
yes we're not just going and looking by
by by hand by eye at what's going on
right
i think that should be a separate
discussion i won't apply to that
okay well so but i mean that certainly
other teams know how to do that
so if if you guys don't know how to do
it
if it's not it's not the issue we have
the tools
okay all right okay
okay
well that seems like a nasty bug
and and has qa successfully
characterized it or you say it's too
intermittent to characterize
the deed is actually reported and you
know before even the user reported it
and it's well characterized we know when
it happened we well we don't know it it
seems to be intermittent right i mean we
actually know the piece of code where it
happened so is that is this the state of
the
you know our memory allocator right we
have our internal memory allocator which
are located memory right from the
operating system so if it happened that
you know when we get the memory it fits
into current memory allocator which will
handle it will not crash
but if it gets outside that in any case
both are an issue but if you get outside
that then the system crash
so it's pretty much explained why we
have both card you know sometimes you
crash sometimes it doesn't yeah okay
okay that's nasty
all right
discretize region and discretized
graphics behave differently
to fix to mix precision inputs
right so that one is similar to the one
above we
you know
that's a treatment of numerical
precision yes which is a tricky business
right and one key thing is that our
geometry or the mesh
framework we have is essentially machine
precision i mean for performance and
such
that's right so and we are progressively
you know handling higher precision right
our general precision framework you know
we improve region
bond
i think his bonding ratio completely to
support all our beta representation even
exact
so we are kind of progressively you know
propagating into the whole system
well what is
different behavior with fixed precision
so
fixed precision meaning machine
precision
white
yeah well i'm sorry that's what you sign
up for the idiocy of machine precision
not our fault the fact that the whole
stack of technology has been built with
the ieee floating point standard
is terrible
but not something we can fix
i mean is there more to it than that
that different algorithms are going to
give to different treatments of
numerical round-off
right and you know we are trying our
best inside to adjust all that i mean to
return you the correct results
it's falling that whole framework of you
know more robustness you know in terms
of whatever input the user give whatever
noise we try to adjust it so
and we have it a lot in geometry right
people can give really degenerate
questions you can give it an angle which
is going to [ __ ] your life
i know that's the bane of of of
computational geometry as all those
degenerate cases
okay we're seeing something from sander
here on
what's wrong with that
looks perfect to me
oh
no
[Music]
that's a weird case right so the point
here is
only the position of the dodohedron has
been made
fixed precision
its volume still could be exact
boy that's a subtle issue
and we have a design decision on that i
mean we are critical on that it's
the global precision of the expression
is machine precision in that case it
doesn't matter the details
right i'm not handling by case by case
is that documented
uh
i don't think so i don't think let's
make sure that's documented i i agree
that that's a perfectly reasonable
decision
i don't full sorry i don't fully
understand it's just the point is
right so you know the volume of the
dodecahedron it doesn't matter
where in you know in finite precision
space the dodecahedron is placed i see
okay okay
but it's a reasonable decision that if
there's any machine precision in there
make the whole thing machine position
it's just like if i say you know some
bessel function
with you know one of its arguments
machine precision even if it turns out
that the result is independent of that
we still give machine precision
yeah it's definitely consistent with
almost everything else we do so
um
okay so i want to come back to ali
has a comment about a four-year-old bug
in fine maximum flow
can we find find maximum flow can we
find that bug
and um somebody search for that in the
bugs database
i'm looking
do you know charles i mean you might be
familiar with
maximum probably i think he's probably
obviously i mean it's one also one of
those complex memory issues
no no but wait a minute
okay can we see it
so we're not speculating we can just
look at it
um jay i think is you had it in your
first meeting in the list right
i don't remember exactly
okay
yes
pull up the fine maximum flow book that
you had
the bug number in red mine and or bugs
it doesn't matter
sandra is commenting in the best social
cases direct dependence on the input
there might not be it might be a theorem
that for that value of the you know for
pi over two or something
the result is always exactly zero if the
second argument is pi over two i see the
point the point is i see the point the
point is that if one of them is machine
no no it could be the case that if the
second argument is exactly pi over two
then you already know that independent
of the value of the first argument the
result is zero for example
and i think that's analogous to the
nordic hedon case
in other words the as you think about
kind of the error region
you're right that
with with an exact value for one of the
parameters
you could decide you know you could
i mean i think this is
again it's a subtle issue but
i think it's the same issue as with
vessel functions in this case
i claim it's not different
um okay i i
put the red mine issue uh
i think that's the core thing a number
of people have reported this so it's
probably good to go oh boy
oh boy
okay
there's also i put a red mind link as
well
here is the fix
says charles 10 24
three days ago
yep we i mean we we work on it and we
finally figure out what was the the keys
well so then we declare victory on this
one then right and i can tell
god go ahead let's let's go ahead and
look at the red mine version
i missed that did you just say that was
fixed no
three days ago yes it's listed
by charles
i mean that's why jay remove it from the
list i mean he had it in the list
okay okay that could have been in the
list of recently fixed
right but it wasn't it wasn't like
tested yet so i didn't want to give like
a
falsehood
so so it fell in the in the in the chasm
or crack between it is an open issue and
it is a resolved issue
and therefore it is it is an issue of
which one cannot speak
the viewers the viewers that are
privileged pre-release testers have
access to daily bills so if this is
actually in bills then you know we can
but it sounds like it is
even
is the pr merged or not charles yep it's
much
so it's in the build
yeah you should be
okay so okay so let's let's look at the
the case that was reported here and
declare victory
yeah okay that sounds good let's uh
just for some for some
uh just for ali's information since he's
you know
experienced this bug for a while
what
um
uh
can you give some characterization of
what happened here charles
um yes
so in this specific case is when you
compute the maximal flow with edge
capacity
and it's
you know we kind of need to rewrite the
optimization problem you know or
construct the graph essentially
and then
pretty much we emulate the capacity has
you know by introducing a new edge and
controlling the flow between the edges
so during that process we actually need
to reconstruct the graph and copy the
information right so during that process
where we copy the information that there
was uh
you know an error again a pointer error
when we were copying
original data
to the new constructed graph
why did it take four years to find that
because it was complicated to find
because pointer error as in
the wrong pointer was passed and it just
gave the wrong answer
or pointer error as in the pointer
pointed into la la land and the thing
crashed
um actually that's the thing it was not
crashing so what essentially was again
happening is that you know
again we you know the way we allocate
memory
you know we were copying the pointer and
not readjusting it you know at the
beginning of the list so he was still
copying and he was copying wrong values
okay so it was not crashing but just
that way it's also named different
values it was assigning capacity
in an incorrect way
and had it been i mean it looked like
from that bug report there was a fair
amount of internal activity trying to
fix that it just didn't get
found until you jump in until you dived
in and found it
yeah and i've been looking at it for a
while now too so it's um
it's one of those which you know at the
end is you know it's quite simple but
you know when you look at the whole code
and try to trace down where it actually
happened
sure sure and it sometimes looks bugs
look easy like there's a long-standing
bug with absolute options of graphics
right like that that should be giving
better results and you know that's been
reported like over and over and over
again by users
and i think in version 13 if i'm not
mistaken brett actually made a lot of
progress in addressing all these issues
i think he didn't talk about that at the
conference so you know sometimes you
know a bug can look very simple like you
know like
you know
it should just work but the work behind
it can be you know like a month of work
i don't know if that's the case with
charles's bug but you know it sounds
like that was just not easy to debug
right
i mean
you know as we move more and more to top
level code it will become easier and
easier to debug things and hopefully
when most of this code is written in
compiler intermediate language not
in
you know not
in sort of raw c code when cases where
it's a you know highly optimized
computational geometry algorithm or
something
the um
uh you know these things will get easier
i would hope
um yes and you know actually even now
it's kind of the direction we are going
passively moving most of the code to the
top level
right i'm just leaving a small subset in
the sea
right
right
um
just for
for a moment i need to go to a different
meeting which i think is also live
stream we're talking about uh
quantum framework um
no no it isn't okay sorry guys
for future okay so just just summarize
for future meetings of this form
more bugs you want direct access to red
mine cues
i mean i think so i mean look i think
it's useful to talk about the the the
goal here is
if there is a bug like this
four-year-old fine maximum flow bug
that bug is an embarrassment
that's what we should be talking about
and at least i'd like to understand and
i think our users would like to
understand you know why wasn't that
fixed okay the answer may be it's really
hard
but and that's okay
you know let's understand that
right yeah and um you know the purpose
of this meeting is to unstick things
where actually there's a way around it
we didn't think of it or whatever else
or
where
uh you know we're actually it's a thing
that's being reported
um
uh
that's a very amusing idea
is that are those available
those those opera those ascii forms for
undirected edge is that possible
is that possible you mean with escape
keys or not no no no this is not escape
keys
this is non-escape key versions
i mean that's maybe a lcc issue
yeah i know that's probably not for this
meeting from the height at edge we used
to essentially use the you know
the less dash create you know create a
dash form in the copy and paste and
things change
this cannot possibly work if it's like
two
2-3
i know i know i know can't work it's
it's it's some right so i mean this
isn't for this meeting these are things
if they're suggestions they should be
fed into the ildq or some appropriate
place like that that's not for this
meeting right but it's super ambiguous
to suggestion i don't think this can
possibly work yeah i don't think it can
work either
um okay two two comments from the live
stream one there was a comment about
sending out rolling updates for things
um
that's not in anybody's interest because
it is it is hard enough you know
that you don't want an incremental
version that has not been fully tested
the
we have a whole packlet system and there
are parts of the system that can be
incrementally updated and those are
being uh updated incrementally and are
automatically updated on on yeah
so i have a few things to say about that
the of course we do lots and lots of
paklet updates i mean more and more
stuff is impactlets and we update what's
the frequency what's the typical
frequency of the packet update
in other words
i think it's maybe six ten a week
updates with bug fixes that's all right
and also
in version so those are going so those
are automatically field upgraded
yeah
and then also in version 13
the documentation is separated out like
it'll still be a single you know user
interface but it's it's separated now so
we can do documentation updates more
regularly in principle like full
documentation build updates
well the full one is a huge download i
mean i assume
we've been doing incremental ones yeah
but we're doing like you know two
releases a year we could have like every
quarter we can do a you know
improvements to documentation updates in
principle okay but that would be but
that's different from our point updates
which we are already doing because
they're packed updatable right
so i've got a question
that these are bug fixes so that's you
know people right i've got a question
why
i mean
you know i'm happy that we haven't had
disasters from those six to ten
uh packet updates per week going out but
what if some user is depending on a bug
in the previous packet
dependent on the bug that's depending on
a bug
then well if it's a bug it's a bug and
then you know then they would probably
have to fix you know update their code i
mean no i i realized that but i'm like
like surprised
obviously we're not we're not burning in
the bugs but my question is
the fact that nobody i mean it's an
invisible process basically those
updates
and it should be
well i understand that but my question
is
are we are we not seeing and it's great
if we're not
uh cases where
something mysteriously changes somebody
says i ran it this way one day and i ran
it this way the next day and i got a
different eye i'm not aware of much of
that i mean i'm not either i think it's
great we have every once in a while we
screw up
and then we you know that people tell
support and then we fix it with just
another another update but you know
doesn't happen super often i mean
you know happens maybe well i think
that's a triumph that we're not seeing
that phenomenon right because people
know i just you know uploaded version 13
from 12.3 they know they put in a
version update and if something changes
they know to be suspicious about the
version update but if it's a package
update that happens silently in the
background they don't know to what you
know and we don't have any manifest that
we're putting out about what those are
is that correct
how would somebody know what they were
i mean it sounds to me like you don't
know it's it's very much you know behind
the scenes it's right i mean it's good
it's it's good because that's the way it
should be yeah and on the sorry on the
twitch chat
ali hashmi saying
um have something to say about that the
um
they're talking about bug fixes for
you know like currently
released versions and again
you know that's possible with paclet
updates as well you know if if there's a
bug in the version like say 12 3 0 right
and you don't have anything more recent
right then with packet updates right
there's a minimum version where the bug
fix applies to so we can you know peclet
update can fix a bug for you know 12 0
12 1 12 2 and 12 3. you know like like
that's that
we have that capability of going
backwards in time to fix bugs for
you know versions of wolfram language
that are already out there
does that make sense am i making sense
or
right yes i understand that okay
that's just to address this question is
asking how many open bugs are there
total well uh it's like asking yes but
it starts like asking how many you know
how many puddles are there in this
particular park it depends on you know
whether something is validly counted as
a puddle the internal box database goes
all the way back to 1988 and so you know
everything that's ever been wrong right
is in there so they're you know and
they're about 400 000 total things that
have been reported is that correct yeah
and i don't know like how many open ones
but you know too many i mean be nice if
we
you know fix just bugs but you know
that's that's not how software works
unfortunately well the main problem is
that we don't even know
many of those bugs
the
the thing that says it's a bug is itself
a bug so to speak
and you know one of the things that
happens is
bugs get fixed in quotes because
somebody goes through the bugs database
and discovers that the reports were
confused and the thing that was reported
is in fact not a bug
and so there's a there's something of a
trade-off there
of of you know one can go chasing things
which have been reported which are in
fact not bugs
and especially with older bugs that
drives me nuts it's just you know things
get fixed but the bugs database doesn't
get updated like nobody tells anybody
that you know well nobody knows that
that was that that was something yeah
fix that happened today
reflected on something that was reported
in 1992 for example if i go right if i
go back back to 2006 the bugs for 2006
you know and i start randomly to
retesting bugs then you know typically
you know quite a few are actually fixed
it's just
you know
we just don't have to bandwidth to do
that
you know
in a perfect world we would i mean the
problem is the problem is that there's
another issue which is that if we take
code
take a code base
that you know we can make more harm
if we go and fix
things which are
kind of yes it's a knit and in a perfect
world it would work differently
we go fix it and then we break a bunch
of other stuff in that piece of code
because really what should have happened
is eventually that piece of code should
all have been updated
but it doesn't make sense to go putting
patches in that can actually cause more
harm than good i mean it's a it's a
complicated decision it's it's like
there are things which are genuine bugs
like it is you know definitively wrong
versus oh
uh you know be nice if this worked or
in this weird corner case the thing we
do is not the best thing to do in that
corner case and there's an argument for
why that corner case should be improved
i mean we have some some
sometimes you may be able to fix a bug
but the result of the function you know
the function can get 10 times slower
because of it you know that's another i
guess that's another issue they're like
sometimes you fix a minor bug and then
there's just consequences to everything
so
uh
sandra is suggesting a bug
a bug toba october contest
to kill as many bugs as possible we have
done a number of those things in the
past and they have been fairly
successful and uh you know i take the
point that the 1211 release which was a
bug fix release was a good thing and
expect that we're going to do things
like that again
it's uh you know we
should probably do it for you know
13.0.1 buckfix release in january
february timeframe i would hope so but i
would hope so that would be my
preference
uh
oh okay so there's a comment here
about insects and bugs
oh my gosh this is this is a language
about the word bug which i i you know
the word bug has long ago
separated
from its meaning
as you know it's like like if i use the
word
uh
i don't know
i think the word in english has the most
distinct meanings is set if i use the
word set
to
talk about a train set versus say
something else set
those words have separate meanings even
though they are spelled the same and
pronounced the same i consider the word
bug
applied to a piece of software is not
the same word
as bug as in
uh a
a a a a lovely creepy coralie insect
so yeah
i mean any correspondence between those
is purely historical
um you know every word had an etymology
in which typically the word had you know
was at one time had the same meaning and
then separated in meaning and i think
this is a word i you know we're going to
use the word bug because that's what
people call this and you know if it
reminds you of the insect version well
fine but to a software engineer it's
primarily telling you about the thing
that we mean by bug
sometimes you talk about issues as well
but you know like there's still the term
debugging right which is based on bugs
as well
right i mean it's one of these things
where it could have been you know a
piece of soot that got into that early
computer and these things could have
been called you know something different
um it's just
what's that dust
specs or yeah okay any case ali is
commenting that
um the issue is if there is a fix for a
bug then release this for the current
version
that's what we talked about we just
addressed that we can do that for
paclets but for
non-paclic code we can't do that
in order to you know the code has is an
integrated thing
and you can't release you can't backport
a fix typically to an earlier code base
it just doesn't work i mean there's one
interesting thing there's apple has a i
forget what
there was a bug in apple where
if apple had released this bug we would
have had to go back to 12 3 and b
earlier to fix it it was an issue with
linear algebra being completely broken
because of some register 18 issue
so we actually already made a 12-3-1
new build
just in case
you know apple apple did fix it apple
did fix it and so we're holding that in
the reserve but
if apple still you know breaks that
functionality in the future at least
we'll probably
roll that out no reason to think they
would break it i mean they you know they
know probably from us and other people
that was broken and they fixed it
but if they happen to do it in march or
something right 12-3 users
yeah we'll get a thick we already fixed
it we just decided let's not release it
because it just you know that's just
going to be disruptive but yeah well
there's no point in releasing because
the only people who have it will be
people who are pre-released testers for
apple right
yes yeah yeah it just showed up in one
of apple's betas earlier this year and
then we spent you know fair amount of
time and effort to to get that fixed um
right i don't think that that's
something we can sign up for i mean in
other words in general if if it is in a
beta operating system
and you know we'll try to fix it but i
don't think we can be you know we
support released operating systems not
uh you know beta versions of operating
systems
yeah yeah but it showed up there and and
you know people started noticing and
there were test failures and you know we
just
it's an exceptional case but sometimes
we do go back in time and release in you
know another update
yeah
okay a point from ethan add automatic
performance checks look for time
space complexity regressions we
certainly have such tests
you know having the completeness of
those tests is a is a
uh you know a hugely computationally
difficult and ultimately undecidable
type problem
but uh it's not like we don't have any
such tests
exactly i mean we measure every
you know test case as timing and so we
we record that then we do notice like
overall you know like if something slows
down a lot we can analyze all that
um right on the other hand remember what
is saying here is more like take one
function and go into some parameter
space and then figure out you know like
that's harder to do like across the
system i mean yes you can do it for some
functions but
just just to explain that point i mean
the fact is
that
it is not a bug necessarily that this
very fast case of some function got
three percent slower
because
you know
you know the function was rewritten and
many things got 20 times faster but this
particular thing got three percent
slower
you know that's presumably
that's something that should not be
considered a bug
because you know it's one of these
things where in in principle you say
well nothing should get slower
but in a sense anytime you're doing a
computation where you don't already know
the answer
you're doing the computation the only
way you can find out what's going to
happen is to do the computation so it's
not
you know there's no way to say oh it
should never get slower um
and you know the only question is is the
is the distribution and it can be even
more complicated i mean if you take
something like a factor integer which
has huge variations in timing depending
on the particular energy you feed it um
you know there's there's this question
of what is the correct
uh
you know way to assign
i mean in a perfect world you would have
an a priori distribution of possible
computations people want to do and you
would say if you take that a priori
distribution of probabilities of
computations then what is the average
slowness for a particular average speed
increase or decrease for a particular
person based on the distribution of
computations they want to do that isn't
something that that is an unrealistic
thing
other than anecdotally so to speak to
try to assess
i mean this is this relates to certain
questions about the p versus np problem
and my belief that there's certain
aspects of that that aren't even very
well possible to define in in axiomatic
systems et cetera et cetera et cetera
but we will get ourselves off track by
talking about that
um
the
ali is asking so why
is replace pixel value broken
for their previous version
what does that see a bug that alias
reported for um a slowdown i don't know
if this is the same bulk or another one
but the slowdown that i'm looking at is
fixed for 13. i think we should find a
way of reporting it back on redmine that
this is going to be fixed in 13. it's
still marked as open
in red mine
or actually that one is marked as
resolve so i take that back girl j
should take a note about and follow up
with you to see what
what's going on there
i made a note
thank you all right ali is commenting
about comparing timings we do tons and
tons of comparisons of timings for of
all sorts of different things i mean the
problem is this isn't a simple problem
and uh you know as
it might be obvious even from this
meeting looking at specific bugs things
get quite subtle quite quickly
and you know again you have to kind of
figure out what is the optimal frontier
of
uh you know the difficulty of analyzing
what's going on versus what should be
built versus what is worth building
that's new
versus etc etc and you know the reason
uh discussions like this are useful
is to help us understand
and help
you know what priorities should be but
it isn't a we're doing something stupid
and uh you know it's obviously wrong i
don't think so i think these are it's a
pretty complicated problem and we are
attempting to carve out an optimal
frontier between what's new
what's what should be fixed because it
will make it better as opposed to it
it reminds one of if you kind of like
you know medical interventions where you
could say well you could fix that but
then this would go wrong and uh
you know that won't be a win overall
um
but uh
um
no i i think ali is taking for bug fix
slows down the function does not mean to
not fix the function
uh up to a point up to a point i mean
you know like you could say
uh you know we can improve the numerical
precision of this
but it will be a hundred times slower
what do you do
right now we get you know five digit
precision we could get 15 digit
precision but it will be 100 times
slower what should we do
yeah i mean you could run everything in
the wall from language at 100 digit
precision and you'll get better results
right and and the goal as much as
possible 100 times slower probably right
yeah but the goal as much as possible is
to provide those choices to users so
they can decide what to do but you know
sometimes there's a there's a there's a
you know it is an issue we know
that
you know we could make something
more accurate but it will be
unbelievably much slower and again it
has to do with this you know what is the
optimal frontier between
making it
you know making it
more higher precision let's say versus
slower and that's everything
judgment call yeah we do have a lot of
that
as method options like andy has tons and
tons of method options where if you pick
one
option right you get
better results but it takes longer or
you know you you pick another method
and you get faster results but maybe not
social is commenting that having more
things in packages
look they that's what our paclet updates
do and as we were just hearing there are
six to ten such updates per week
so yes that's a you know that's that's
what we're doing that's the direction
we're moving in on the other hand just
saying we put everything in packages
that's a absolutely abominable solution
in terms of having a large-scale
coherent system
for the long term that is absolutely not
what you want i mean in other words the
function repository is wonderful and
allows us to deliver a lot of things
quickly but the functional repository
does that by not
maintaining the kind of design integrity
that we try to maintain for our long
term system
and that means that you know i can write
a function repository entry and i've
done so in five minutes
the minimum time to write a built-in
function
is you know just probably a thousand
times that that time
and and that's because you know we're
building something which is coherent
which fits into the system which we want
to commit to and we have successfully
committed to you know over the course of
many decades and you know it's it's a
different problem and you know it's one
of these things where
it's it's a it's a frustrating thing
about software sometimes you know it can
look as if
things are you know it's like oh look
it's so easy i can just do this
and you rush forward and you do one
particular thing and it's like oh my
gosh
the uh a very extreme example of this i
tell a little story and i need to go
after this was a a person um
i i guess i knew long ago um
who contracted to build an operating
system for a company it's a long time
ago and people people did that
and um
they uh
they had this demo working in a weekend
where there was a windowed early
windowed operating system they had a
demo working it brought up windows
um
and uh but it did it rather slowly
five years later
with a large team
they had not managed to finish the
operating system even though at the
beginning the first weekend they did
something spectacular it did amazing
things that were very state-of-the-art
it just turned out that was a different
problem from the problem of actually
getting the systematic
software built
and uh you know that that that's that's
where things when you're prepared to
have
less unified design
less robust you know implementation and
so on yes you can jump ahead and do
things very quickly and our goal with
the function repository and so on is to
get the best of both worlds to have the
ability to deliver things that are
far ahead of our main curve
while recognizing that those things are
not intended to be you know in in 30
years the things that are in the
function repository today will still be
in the function repository but
many of them will have been overtaken by
systematic things that have been built
into the system and that we can commit
to for the future so to speak
um but on the other hand some of those
things might have been the leading way
to do something in the functional
repository for 15 years and that means
that things can get done 15 years ahead
of when they would have been done with
things that are built into the system so
at least that's our theory of it and um
i think i think it's a pretty good
solution i think the solution is not
to go and say oh let's have this
hedgehog of random functionality that we
sort of say is vaguely related to the
system
um
it's uh uh
um
i think um
there's all sorts of interesting
comments here
um
ali is commenting something gets
released it should be comparable better
than state of the art that's an
interesting
it's an interesting statement
we'd certainly like that to be the case
but here's the trade-off and this is the
thing i fight with and we fight with
internally quite a bit
there are teams i could name them
where everything they deliver will be
state of the art or beyond state of the
art
okay that's the good news
it will be spectacular wonderful pushing
the envelope etc
the bad news is it might take eight
years to do that
five years whatever might take a long
time to do it so the question is in the
intervening time is it better to have
released something
that
doesn't give wrong answers but it isn't
as fast as it could be for example
or is it better to wait for the extra
five years
that's a complicated trade-off yeah i
mean i think shot is still with the
video processing right i mean we we
that's the long-term project where we
have deliverables along the way right
and the initial releases are not
necessarily state-of-the-art but you
know it will be
i mean version 13 you know we're pretty
close
well we have a big experimental tag
above the whole thing yeah yeah
right
i mean but you know it is it is correct
that there are many things where you
know by the time it's stable
and
you know not experimental and so on it
better be state of the art or beyond
um
and state of the art itself moves
constantly as well it's you know
what state-of-the-art today is not you
know it's not state-of-the-art in five
years
that's it's not a
static
endpoint
right
i mean you could have state of the art
image processing today in wolfram
language but doesn't mean that five
years from now it's still going to be
you know state of the art
well indeed although an awful lot of
stuff we've built
i mean you know many things have
turnaround times of over 25 years in
terms of algorithm advances
um but some things you know there are
areas like machine learning which have
advanced rapidly although that's slowing
down now
um and uh uh you know and that's um i
think we did pretty well at um at uh
climbing that hill at the right time now
we in that particular case the things we
did we spent a lot of effort on
technologies i mean we're now on our
third
underlying
uh framework for implementing image
processing and we may very well go on to
yet another generation of that and
that's a lot of work each time and i'm
i'm kind of glad we did all of those
because it allowed us to deliver things
on a timely basis but it's complicated
um
and i i
i'm um
ali is commenting a wrong answer is
wrong answer without exception
i wish that was it was as clear-cut as
that
uh you know we've been having this
argument about binomial coefficients
with negative uh
arguments and you know there's a there's
an argument for one version there's an
argument for another version i think
arguably we picked the wrong thing
and that's something we're reviewing
um
you know i will say i i'm going to make
one last comment and then i really
should go and this is about the ieee
floating point standard
um again i probably i've told this story
before but um
you know
it has the idea that it will always give
you 16 digits of precision even if 10 of
those digits are completely wrong and
even if in the internal computation you
could know that they're completely wrong
now in our arbitrary position arithmetic
for the last 33 years or whatever we
have done
what i think is a correct version of
this
and we do tag which digits are correct
and which digits which digits we know to
be incorrect and we just don't give
those digits we we you know manage the
precision to give you only digits which
are correct
but the ieee floating point standard
which is what is built in to 100 of all
floating point units of all computers
around the world does not have that idea
and the the person who was responsible
for that i certainly uh
discussed this point with him and his
main argument is well people who use
numerical you know approximate numerical
computations
should do the numerical analysis to work
out whether they're getting the right
answer that is an incredibly silly thing
to say
it's an incredibly user-hostile thing to
say
and of course the person who said it is
a numerical analysis professor so it's
his business so it has been i think he's
probably retired now but but um uh was
his business to um uh you know to teach
people that numerical analysis but the
reality is most people most of the time
when they're flying their rocket nobody
is doing i think the winner probably in
the department of of
closest to real-time numerical analysis
is mike foale an astronaut who was this
is years ago was on the mer space
station when some accident happened and
actually was doing computations with
with uh
with our technology um to you know
figure out how to stop the space station
spinning uh the russian ground
controllers wouldn't let him actually
implement the thing he thought should be
done but so it goes um but uh uh that's
that's probably the closest to
um
he wasn't didn't have to do numerical
analysis he was just using i suspect
solving differential equations and so on
um but uh uh you know generally it is
not realistic to have i mean that that's
an example of how quotes wrong answers i
mean you know the ieee floating point
standard has probably produced more
wrong answers and more bad you know than
than than sort of that that's probably
the winner and historical winner for
most wrong answers generated by
computers in the history of our
civilization
and um uh unfortunately the trade-off is
if you don't use it if you say well
we're just gonna that's a bad idea
then you're doing your arithmetic and
software and it's going to be 20 times
slower at least
um and you know what we see happening
with neural nets is a repeat of that
same situation
a
little bit different issue and it's not
about precision but where the particular
you know architectures that exist today
are being burnt into hardware
and those will go really fast and even
if there's a much better idea in the
future
you know we're going to be stuck forever
with essentially compiling things to the
particular architectures that exist
today and i need to go because i'm
really late for something else and i uh
i'll
that these it's a very these are
interesting issues and we can talk about
them some more but it does not
uh i would uh i would like to claim that
it is not nearly as cut and dried an
issue of of whether you know sometimes
there are cut and dried wrong answers
and yes
those are obviously a high priority to
fix
but
there's an awful lot of grey areas where
it's like well yes you could argue
that's what it should do or
or
et cetera et cetera et cetera and all
these ones to do with numerical
precision are just a horrible horrible
quagmire
um anyway and in those cases we tend to
give users the you know options right
like
the option mechanisms like you know you
can either get
yeah well right
arrow quality you can have your cake
needed to like you can
that's a typical thing is the
performance goal option is a good way to
select yeah
exactly exactly all right i have to run
off um okay well thanks all for for um
uh
um
um
participating yes for participating and
uh we we will we will continue to
improve this process um it would be much
better you know ali is commenting we
only discussed three or four bugs and
yeah i had expected much more than that
um
and uh and you know clearly this is a
tiny tip of an iceberg here and
hopefully we get to see more of the
iceberg another time
we we will continue to debug this
process
um all right i've got to run off here
see you guys soon